là monsieur bonsoir c'est par
l'intermédiaire d'un journal proche des
milieux intégristes que le gia
le groupe islamique armé a fait savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il était en fait l'auteur
de l'enlèvement des sept moines
trappistes français disparus en algérie
il y à un mois
le gia se propose de libérer ces
religieux qui serait toujours en vie en
échange de militants prisonniers
notamment en france gilles rabin depuis
un mois malgré le ratissage systématique
de cette montagne de l'atlas par l'armée
algérienne
on restait sans nouvelle des sept moines
trappistes du monastère de tibhirine
enlevés le 27 mars dernier par un
commando islamiste non identifié ce
matin un journal publié à londres al
hayat site sur sa une un communiqué du
gia qui revendique l'enlèvement demande
au gouvernement français à jacques
chirac d'échangé contre des membres du
gia emprisonné en france
les sept moines sinon conclut le
communiqué nous les tuerons ce
communiqué n'est pas très rassurant
puisque il menace d'exécuter les moines
si on ne répond pas à leurs demandes et
qui sont pas d'ailleurs très précises
entre nous pour le moment on ne peut que
continuer de crier et
est ainsi fier notre prière peut-être ne
se sentent ils pas contenté de prier
toujours d'après le journal al hayat des
instances catholiques italiennes et
françaises seraient en contact depuis la
mi-avril avec les ravisseurs des sept
moines de tibérine c'est ce journaliste
spécialisé dans les affaires algériennes
pour al hayat qui a publié le premier le
communiqué dont l'authenticité ne fait
aucun doute
al ansar organe officieux du gia publie
le même texte dans sa 148e édition
sortie cet après-midi highway je suppose
et ce n'est que mon interprétation ce
n'est basée sur aucune information
concrète que des négociations secrètes
qui se seraient tenues en algérie entre
les ravisseurs et la france ont échoué
france hypothèse en forme de question
la réponse ne se trouvera pas à londres
mais peut-être à alger ou à paris
[Musique]